philip mountbatten's association with
the royal navy
started as a baby in 1922
during the greco-turkish war his family
were exiled from corfu on a british
gunboat
hms calypso 18 month old philip was
it's rumored smuggled out in an orange
crate
he went straight from school into the
navy and only a few weeks after that
first meeting between he
and princess elizabeth in dartmouth
world war ii broke out
and prince philip was sent to sea the
war moved seaward
to cape matapan where admiral
cunningham's mediterranean fleet scored
such a smashing victory over the
italians
during the conflict he served with
distinction and climbed the ranks
most notably he was mentioned in
dispatches for his bravery during the
battle of matapan
he was running the searchlights onboard
valiant and three very heavy
italian cruisers were sunk and he was
mentioned in dispatches by
cunningham for his performance then so
you know already he was showing
quite a lot of grit he was a great
sportsman he was very popular
he was a chap you know it was quite
clear he was going to go far
in 1950 the newly married prince and
princess
moved to malta as philip took command of
hms magpie
it was a memorable and enjoyable period
for the young couple
the only time they lived outside britain
and unbeknown to the prince
it would be the pinnacle of his service
commander philip mountbatten's naval
career was cut short
when king george vi died in 1951.
he left military service reluctantly to
be the queen's consort
he had a very promising naval career
ahead of him
uh he he started off when he was at
dartmouth been top cadet
uh of his term uh he'd had an extremely
successful career
he could easily have reached the top of
his profession so
particularly given how much he seems to
have generally enjoyed his life in the
service to have to give that
up at such an early age i mean obviously
he must have known
that he would eventually but he can't
possibly have imagined that it would be
so early on in his career we will never
know how much it affected him
although he did once hint at some
frustration
in a rare interview although prince
philip's military career was cut
shorter than he would have liked his
association with the armed forces
continued throughout his life amongst
his many honorary appointments across
the commonwealth
the duke of edinburgh became admiral of
the sea cadet corps
marsh of the royal air force and colonel
in chief of the british army cadet force
it was a sign of his duty to the armed
forces that his final
official solo engagement was to take the
salute from the royal marines
aged 96 and in the pouring rain
he was the captain general of the marine
corps for 64 years
a role that he cherished and the last
time the duke was seen in public
was in the summer of 2020 when he stood
down as colonel in chief of the rifles
and handed the title
to his daughter-in-law camilla it ended
in association with the regiment
that stretched all the way back to 1953.
we were all very proud of the juvenile
and he had served for six years through
the war
you know he had shown he had shown his
metal he was a brave officer
um he was an old-fashioned naval officer
you know he he was old-fashioned in his
view
and that had huge strengths we had a
whole navy full of old-fashioned naval
officers at one stage
you know and they had a great sense of
duty um he loved the navy itself
he knew about seamanship instinctively
um and those things were very important
that he and
and the navy realized that and the navy
loved him for it and he was seen as very
special
on his 90th birthday the queen appointed
prince philip
lord high admiral of the royal navy the
highest rank in the service
that he loved it was recognition of her
husband's lifelong dedication to the
navy
and the professional sacrifice that he
made to serve
her aleister bunkel sky news